[Music]
foreign
binsberg and a finance professor at the
Wharton School of the University of
Pennsylvania and I'm Jonathan Burke a
finaster professor at The Graduate
School of Business at Stanford
University and this is the all else
equal podcast
welcome back everybody today we are
going to talk about how do you
accumulate your wealth over your life
cycle particularly with a retirement
objective in mind so we're going to talk
about things like how much money should
you be putting away every year and what
are reasonable rates of return on your
Investments so that you can achieve a
particular retirement goal that you have
in mind say retiring at 45 or at 55 or
at 65 and so that is what today's
episode is on just as a reminder if you
go to the link in the show notes you can
click there and you can submit ideas for
big problems that you think should be
covered in future episodes of all else
equal so if you have a good idea for an
episode please click on the link in the
show notes and fill out your idea there
so Jules I also like the idea of what
we're going to do today because I think
it illustrates a pretty productive way
to approach an economic decision so in
this case the economic decision is how
do I save for retirement and the best
way to approach a complicated decision
is to simplify the decision and by doing
that get a handle on exactly what the
important inputs are that determine the
decision so what we're going to do today
is think about a simple economic model
and once we've explained the economic
model we can use the economic model to
figure out what are the implications of
saving for retirement as I like to say
to my students an economic model is
really just a way of making an argument
in other words we're not physicists no
economic model is going to work like a
physics model so then why do economists
and practitioners build models it's to
make an argument if the model is
consistent then we know the argument is
consistent and so then the question is
what assumptions lead to what conclusion
so really an economic model is all about
the assumptions and that's exactly what
we're going to do today the other thing
we're going to do is simplify the
problem in the sense that we're not
going to talk about the best portfolio
to hold like the ratio of stocks to
bonds to hold because that is another
episode all to itself so today we're
going to step away from the best
investment strategy and just concentrate
on the question of how much money do you
need to save in order to retire
all right so then let's lay out the
basic ingredients of the model and after
we've set up the model and see what it
implies we can debate each of these
assumptions in turn but here are the
basic ingredients first you are going to
be working for a certain period of time
that certain period of time can be 20
years 30 years or 40 years let's start
off with the simple assumption that you
start working at 25 you work for 40
years and you retire at 65.
then at age 65 you're going to retire
and you will have to live off your
retirement savings for the next 20 years
that is between 65 and 85. now during
the 40 years that you work you're going
to be putting a fraction of your income
into your retirement savings account
that retirement savings account is going
to be invested in some investment
vehicle that's going to deliver a
certain percentage real return per year
and when we say real return we mean the
return that you make after correcting
for inflation so if you make five
percent nominal and the inflation rate
is three percent then your real return
is two percent per year and so now the
key question that we need to ask is
which fraction of your income should you
be putting away in the 40 years that
you're working but this of course
depends on how much you want to consume
in retirement a common assumption is
that in retirement you want to consume
70 of your last earned salary but and
this is important it is the salary left
after the contributions for retirement
have already been made so if you make a
hundred thousand dollars in the year
before retirement and you are putting
away twenty percent of your income to
save for retirement that means that you
had eighty thousand dollars left and so
then what you want to consume during
retirement is seventy percent of that
eighty thousand numbers so that's fifty
six thousand per year and then the last
component of the model is what about the
fact that your income is likely to grow
over your life cycle so if you look at
the data what you find is the median
person's income Grows by about one and a
half percent a year
and the 95th percentile grows it's
something like five percent a year so we
need to make an assumption so let's just
assume that your income will grow at
some rate over your life cycle and those
I think are the basic elements of the
model so now let's see if we saw that
model and look at the numbers
what's one of the most common advice
that we see will lead to so a lot of
financial advisors will tell clients
something like just put away 10 of your
income so the fraction that you save is
ten percent of your income and what you
then find is is that if you want to have
enough money to retire on so that you
can consume 70 of your post contribution
income in retirement
then you will have to assume that you
can make five percent in real terms per
year assuming an average income growth
of one and a half percent and again
we're working under the assumption that
you will work for 40 years between 25
and 65 and retire for the 20 years after
now the question is is that realistic
just to be clear on the Assumption of
how much you're going to retire on
so if you are making a hundred dollars
and you're putting twenty dollars into
your retirement savings account then
what we're saying is you're going to
live on seventy percent of the eighty
dollars yeah so given that assumption as
Jules pointed out you need a five
percent real return which is an
exceptionally High number to put this in
perspective if you look at the real
return on tips which would be a riskless
investment in U.S treasuries the real
return on tips to really exceed two
percent so to expect a return of five
percent is exceptionally optimistic well
so one way in which we can get that
return up would be to take more risk and
as we said risk will be discussed in a
different episode but let's just say one
short thing about it if you take a lot
of risk that also means that the
distribution of possible outcomes you're
going to get is going to be quite wide
and therefore you will have to be
willing to live with the possibility
that you need to live off much less than
that 70 number that we've just mentioned
and so let's not go into that in this
episode but risk in the end is something
we will not be able to avoid we will
have to have that discussion at some
point and we will but the point is I
don't like it when financial advisors
say oh we'll just put it in the stock
market and you can earn a higher return
I mean return doesn't come for free if
you want to put in the stock market then
you have to entertain the possibility of
losses and therefore you won't have
enough money to retire on me one of the
things the Great Recession the crash of
2007 that annoys me is everybody's like
act as a complete surprise what the
stock market could go down I mean what I
think the biggest problem was people
were allowed into believing that you
could just get these higher Returns on
the stock market without ever
encountering any risk so the summary is
simply this if you want to make sure
that you're going to have the money that
we're planning for you will have to
invest it in a risk-free investment
alternative if you're going to take more
risk yes your average return will go up
but it also means you'll have to deal
with that and indeed return doesn't come
for free if you want to invest all your
money in the stock market be prepared to
have to do it much less so if we then
take a realistic real return of two
percent then what you need to save for a
time but it is twice in other words more
like 20 of your income you have to put
into retirement so I think one of the
first insights this model delivers is if
you really want to retire at something
like 70 percent of your post retirement
income it's going to cost you at least
20 percent a year of a money that you
need to put into savings
now if real returns are zero which is
the number that we had for quite a bit
particularly during the covert period
right I mean real rates of return were
exceptionally low if you have no real
return then you have to Triple that so
you have to put away 30 so now let's
talk a bit about growth Jonathan we have
a variation in the population how
quickly your earnings will grow as we
said particularly for our listeners it's
probably closer to the higher end of the
distribution so say that growth rates
are around five percent now our
intuition would be and I think a lot of
people will have that intuition is how
can growth in your income in any way be
bad meaning if my income grows faster
shouldn't that make it much easier to
reach my retirement goal but it's not
quite that simple yeah the issue is
since your retirement is a function of
your final income
the more your income grows the more you
have to put away this is basically a
habit formation model that says when I
get used to being rich I want to stay
rich and that means you have to put more
away not less away so let's just give
you an example let's go back to the five
percent real return calculation where
the market you have to put away is 10 if
I change the rate of growth from one and
a half percent to five percent of the
rate of growth of your income then what
you find is instead of having to put 10
away you have to put 20 away of your
income in other words because you have
so much more consumption when you retire
you have to put away much more in order
to maintain that level of assumption and
if we drop the return from a five
percent real which none of us think is
realistic to a two percent real then you
have to save almost a third of your
income now of course many people people
would say Well when you've got five
percent growth rates in your income
you'll be exceptionally wealthy when it
comes time to retire and therefore you
can take a hit to your retirement easier
and so that is perhaps true but it goes
against the idea that we don't like to
take a hit to our consumption and it
illustrates another point right which is
from a retirement point of view there is
value to not getting used to too lavish
a lifestyle too quickly right so there
is this whole movement going on now and
I don't know whether you've heard about
it where people say let me work really
hard consume very little save a very
large fraction of my income and then
retire early and of course this approach
helps in two ways first because you save
more a very large fraction you build up
your savings quicker but secondly you
don't have this habit formation effect
that you describe because you learn to
live off a very low consumption level
and therefore in retirement you can
continue that same lifestyle that you
had during those working years quite
easy you know this is really a more
General point one of the biggest beasts
I have with retirement advice is when
people say you should start saving for
time and as early as possible now
ignoring the Habit formation just think
about this if you're saving early
and his income growth what you're doing
is you're moving money from your poor
state in other words early in your life
when you don't earn a lot to your Rich
state which is late in life when you
have a lot of money we don't often think
that's a good idea to move money from
your per estate to your Rich state so
the basic idea that you should start
early saving for retirement I think we
have to think about carefully and
especially now let's put into the
context of habit formation and getting
used to consuming I actually think the
advice is that out wrong so John there's
two arguments to add to that one on each
side of the argument right so the first
one is this as you grow your income over
time what is the normal standard of
living of the people around you is also
going to be growing right so in other
words the general standard of living of
the economy is going up and so I'm not
sure that you want to stay behind in
that as you go over time you want to
keep up so we call this external habit
formation you want to keep up with the
rest of society which means that you do
want to be able to grow your consumption
pattern over time and so that is
probably something that our model misses
a little bit out on because we're going
to be assuming also that through the
entire time of your retirement you're
going to be consuming the same amount
and so we have to think that through a
little more perhaps the other thing is
of course the fact that what you're
getting used to is that over time as you
consume more you don't want to scale
back on that consumption all the
evidence suggests that it's incredibly
painful for people to scale back their
consumption levels and by the way I'm
not so sure that I agree with you that
that is all that different for richer
people than for other people I think
that getting used to Lifestyles happens
to everybody really quickly and it
becomes normal before you know it and
scaling back is just painful for
everybody yeah I agree Jules but I also
disagree with you that these two things
actually work against each other and
I'll tell you why I think who you hang
out with is a function of what you make
and what you choose to spend so that you
can control how much you need for
retirement by choosing a lifestyle that
the people around you choose agree so in
other words I would say rather than
start sailing early don't start saving
early but as your income grows
you put more and more into retirement so
you're after retirement income doesn't
grow as much
which means when it comes time for
retirement you haven't built up this
exceedingly High living standard that
you didn't have to keep to so I would
say you can achieve both by putting more
away in retirement in the rich States
you can both lower your internal habit
formation since you're not spending as
much you haven't gotten used to a lavish
lifestyle but also because you're not
meeting a lavish bar style you don't
even pick friends that have had a lavish
lifestyle yes I see your argument
although I think that you know the way
that we pick friends to let that depend
on your retirement contributions seems a
bit no no no on your lifestyle not your
time and contributions on your lifestyle
I think agreed agreed but so I think the
important point is to really understand
the implications
for retirement on how much you choose to
spend on your lifestyle versus what you
choose to save the other thing that you
know you talk about a lot of jewels is
in this model we've assumed 4020 we have
assumed that the day of retirement is
fixed but of course that's not true yeah
there are a bunch of different things
that we can discuss here the first one
is what if you simply want to work for
fewer years and we already discussed
that a little bit that's one but the
other one that we need to discuss which
I think is a hugely undervalued point is
the following re-entering the workforce
after you've been out of it is a very
difficult thing to do and so in the
economics literature we call this an
irreversible decision
now before you take an irreversible
decision you better be sure that this is
the right decision because you are
giving up value by pulling that trigger
to say it differently
if you are not committed to say retiring
when you're 65 and you're willing to
just see how things are by the time
you're 65 and depending on your wealth
situation you simply decide to retire
later or maybe if you've reached a
retirement goal better you can retire
earlier than 65 by making this a
flexible thing I think we can add a lot
of value to people's lives and therefore
I've always been surprised that in many
countries and in many pension systems
it's being presented as if being able to
retire at 65 is somehow a good thing
that that's a fixed number that
everybody can focus on and that there's
no negotiation about where that number
exactly is we're now talking about in
European countries to make it from 65 to
67 and you can see for example in France
how many protests that leads to but the
whole idea that this needs to be a
mandatory fixed number I've always found
that strange and also Jules getting back
to our discussion of your lifestyle you
know some people may say to me Jonathan
I want to have a fancy Lifestyle the way
I'm going to finance it is I'm just not
going to retire
right I want to live work hard and play
hard
and I think you're right people have the
choice to make that so of course if you
retire later
you have much fewer years in retirement
to finance and therefore you can have a
bigger lifestyle and you don't have to
put a third of your money away so I
think it's very important to understand
that people approach the problem
differently and have one size fits all
is I think a mistake and as you say it
ignores the real option I mean that's
the other thing you could imagine that
although you've got an average growth
rate in income for many people the
actual growth rate of the income is very
uncertain right some people make it well
some people don't and so working on
averages is in some way hiding the huge
role of this uncertainty one way of
dealing without uncertainty one way with
dealing that at risk is to understand
that the point of retirement is a
function of how well you do for sure if
you happen to do really well you'd get
to retire early if that's what you want
to do and if you happen to do less well
well you just have to work hard no for
sure so one movement that I think you've
seen a lot is that the the entire
pension sector even when it comes with
its defined contribution or defined
benefit seems to be focused on the
desire to do this uniformization where
we have the same Target date fund or the
same pension plan or the same investment
strategy or the same contribution rate
or the same retirement age everything is
about making everything the same for
everybody whereas I think that depending
on the profession that you have
depending on the success that you have
throughout your lifetime depending on
the preference that you have for the
social context that you get out of work
relative to other jobs I think there's
huge heterogeneity that is being ignored
and so I think that maybe the biggest
takeaway of this episode is that this
one size fits all is probably something
that we should get off of well you know
Jewels Target date fans and just for our
listeners don't know what a Target date
fund is it's a fund where you start with
a lot of investments in equity and fewer
investments in bonds and then over your
laptop the fun moves from equity ready
to bonds and this has become a hugely
profitable sector for money management
companies and these were introduced
during my lifetime as a finance
professor and I remember when they were
introduced originally I was very much
against this and I'm still very much
against this because there's no such
thing as one size fits all people have
very different risk preferences they
have very different retirement
preferences and often the target date
funds are presented as one solution and
I think it's a huge mistake to approach
retirement that way and I think it's
pretty self-serving in the industry to
try to pretend that one size fits all so
one another example where I know Jaws
you have strong feelings well one fast
fits all are the pension contributions
of companies right yeah so in the
Netherlands there was this whole debate
on a reform of the pension system and
one key thing there was that a large
group of people that were independent
entrepreneurs were not yet in a pension
plan and so the new law proposal had in
it that what they wanted to achieve is
that even people that work for
themselves so they're independent they
don't work as a worker for a company
that they still should be mandatorily
participating in these pension
arrangements and I never quite
understood why that's a sensible thing
to do particularly because again this
comes to a large cross-sectional
variation between people once we know
that somebody wants to take a lot of
risk is interested in swinging for
defenses by starting their own company
do you really want to force the those
people to not use all the money they
have to try to make that work but rather
force them to take money out of that
entrepreneurial activity and put it into
a pension Arrangement couldn't that
potentially even lower the amount of
entrepreneurial ideas and firm creation
that we have in the economy by imposing
such system-wide changes yeah I mean it
just ignores the fact that people are
different and it's one size does not fit
all so that's I would say very bad
public policy the other thing I know you
have strong feelings about is the mass
contributions of employers right yeah so
we talked a little bit about
substituting money from poor states to
Rich States and I think that that
argument has a lot of bites particularly
for the people that really can't afford
to make the contributions right so many
employers have this matching plan and
the matching plan implies that if you
contribute say three percent then the
employer will match it with three
percent but it also means that if you
cannot make to three percent
contribution you don't lose out on three
percent to your retirement contributions
you lose out on six percent of them and
so for those people that already have
such low salaries that they're so
liquidity constrained that they can
actually not make that three percent
contribution in the poor state do we
think it's good public policy to give
the incentive to try to put that three
percent away and only then match it
don't get me wrong we did a whole
episode on incentives I understand the
power of incentives but incentives only
work when the person actually has a
choice that they can make if the choice
is not really a choice you can provide
as much incentives as you want and of
course you can just see it in the data
right you can see that for the lowest
earning groups that is already
struggling to make ends meet we're
seeing that putting the incentive in
place makes no difference if putting the
incentive in place makes no difference
then why are you putting it in place you
know I always think about this in terms
of buying a house so you know this huge
transaction costs in terms of selling a
house and buying another house and so
the optimal thing to do is to try to buy
as big a house as you can
so you can stay in the house for the
longest amount of time and if that's the
optimal thing to do given all the
transaction costs of changing houses
never mind the human costs are moving
and the fact that your kids have friends
in the neighborhood ignoring even those
costs if that's the optional thing to do
you don't want to have to force we will
put money into retirement which lowers
the size of the house they can buy
initially so again this idea of one size
fits all is a pernicious idea which I
think we really have to think about in
terms of this public policy of how we
approach the retirement decision all
right so let's wrap up and let's talk
about what I think are the key takeaways
of the episode today and I think several
of these takeaways are actually
non-trivial things so the first one
which I think is an important one is
that getting used to a particular
lifestyle implies that you need more
money in retirement if you want to
continue that lifestyle after retirement
so what we call habit formation the
second important Insight I think is that
rates of return are actually quite low
right now particularly in real terms and
so if you want to make retirement goals
with a relatively High degree of
certainty the 10 number of savings that
we had in place so far as the
recommendation may actually be too low
and numbers closer to 20 or 30 percent
may be warranted the third one is that
retirement decisions because they're
irreversible are not to be taken lightly
and so you give up what we call and
finance a real option value because
returning into the labor force is very
difficult after you have retired
particularly after you've been retired
for say a year or two and so maybe
therefore particularly in countries that
have part-time working Arrangements
part-time retiring may be a better
strategy so that you can scale back up
your labor contract if it would be
needed and then finally and I think we
hammered this one a lot is the one size
fits-all broadly speaking in pension
land may lead to not optimal outcomes
the last thing I would say is on the
amount that retirement where 10 we're
saying 10 is too low and you need a
close to twenty percent I think many
people would react by saying it's twenty
percent of my income I can't afford to
put that aside and I think my answer
then is to say okay put 10 aside but
then if you put 10 aside you should be
accepting of the fact that you may not
be able to retire as soon as you think
you'll be able to retire yes that the
4020 rule is probably not right I mean
we have medical advances so you can it's
more like a 50 10 rule that you may have
to do with and again the real option and
the flexibility to retire is important
like if you get to 65 and you're in very
poor health well obviously it's going to
be harder to work but by the same token
you're probably not going to live as
long so there are these questions you
can do later on in retirement and so
that allows you to put less money aside
so long as you understand though that
the implication is that you're probably
gonna have to work longer
thanks for listening to the all else
equal podcast please leave us a review
at Apple podcast we'd love to hear from
our listeners and be sure to catch our
Next Episode by subscribing or following
our show wherever you listen to your
podcast for more information and
episodes visit all else equalpodcast.com
or follow us on LinkedIn the ol SQL
podcast is a production of Stanford
University's Graduate School of Business
and is produced by University FM
[Music]
thank you
foreign
[Music]